Ager: So my name
is Mads Ager.
I'm a software engineer
at Google.
And I work
on the V8 JavaScript engine.
And this talk is going
to be about the internals of V8.
So what did we do,
uh, to make V8 fast
and what were our design,
uh, decisions when making V8?
So here's the agenda
of the talk.
So the main part of the talk
will be about the design goals
and the overall goals
that we had for V8.
And, um, the internals.
So what did we actually do?
Uh, what are the techniques
that we used to make V8 fast?
Um, and that involves
things like hidden classes,
uh, native code generation
using inline caching,
and precise generational
garbage collection.
So that'll be the main part
of the talk
where I explain
these--these things.
So, um, after that,
I'll tell you something
about a couple of recent
developments in V8.
So the first one
is that we implemented
a new JavaScript regular
expression engine
completely from scratch.
And the other one
is that we've built
a new compile
infrastructure.
I'm just going
to briefly mention those
and tell you a bit
about them.
Um, and then I'll go
into something
that, um, I think
is really important.
Uh, and I've called it
object heap scalability here.
Or JavaScript scalability.
And that's all about how well
your JavaScript engine deals
with running really,
really big web applications
where you have
a lot of objects.
Uh, and therefore,
extra pressure
on your memory management
system.
Um, and I think that
this is really important.
And I think that it has been
underemphasized so far.
Um, so I'm going to spend
a bit of time
talking about that.
And then at the end,
I'm going to just,
uh, tell you a bit about some
of the performance bottlenecks
that we have in V8 right now,
uh, which will give you
sort of an indication
of the kind of things
that we like to, uh,
to work on in V8
to make it even faster.
Okay, so for this talk,
the first question is really
why did Google want
to build a new JavaScript
engine?
And the answer
is pretty simple.
So we believe that
in order
to build, uh, the next wave
of big,
uh, web applications,
you need better JavaScript
performance.
Um, and at the time
when the V8 project started,
the existing
JavaScript engines
were not very fast.
So basically
they were all interpreters
working on abstract syntax trees
or on bytecodes.
And they had, uh, poor memory
management systems,
which led
to big pause times,
um, and maybe even,
uh, memory leaks.
Um, so we wanted
to try to change this picture.
We wanted to try to push,
uh, JavaScript performance.
Uh, and we thought that
the best way to do that
was to build a completely
new JavaScript engine
from scratch so that we could do
our own designs
and start completely
from scratch.
Um, so the overall goal
for V8
is to push the performance bar
for JavaScript.
Not only for Google Chrome
and for V8,
but we wanted to kind of try
to push the industry
and see if we can get, uh,
better JavaScript performance
in browsers in general,
which will benefit
all of us.
It'll benefit Google
because we can do better
web applications.
And it'll benefit
the users as well
because, well, users like
web applications as well.
So we wanted to build
a really fast JavaScript engine.
So why is that a challenge?
Well, JavaScript is a very,
very dynamic language.
So objects are basically
just HashMaps.
So you can add and remove
properties,
um, to and from objects
on the fly
in any order you like.
And you have,
uh, no type structure.
So if you want to do,
uh, a property lookup
on an object in JavaScript,
you don't know anything
statically about the object.
So if you have an object,
you want to search
for the X-property,
you have to do exactly that.
You have to search.
So you have to look
in your HashMap.
If it's not there,
you need to traverse
the prototype chain
and look for it there.
And that's, like,
really slow.
So if you compare that
to static,
object-oriented languages
where you have a notion of type,
where you have classes,
if you do a property load
in a language
where you have a notion
of class,
well, then the class tells you
the layout of your object.
So if you want to access
an X-property
on an object
that has a certain class,
then the class tells you
the index
in your object
for that property.
So you can generate
just a few assembly line--
assembly instructions
that will load your property.
In JavaScript, if you just
do it, uh, like naively--
implement JavaScript--
then you'll have a full search
of--of a number
of HashMaps in a chain.
And that's really slow.
Um, right, so JavaScript
is highly dynamic.
You can add properties
to objects.
You can remove properties
from objects.
Um, and, uh,
you can actually change
prototype chains
as well dynamically.
So you can change basically
everything,
uh, in your program
on the fly.
Also, JavaScript has a couple
of language features,
um, that--that could
give you trouble as well.
So one of them is eval.
So eval is a function
that you can call with a string
to evaluate that string
as JavaScript code.
And that's actually
not so bad.
The problem with it is that
it can also change
the calling context.
And that means that,
um, if you're trying
to implement JavaScript,
you really want to have
some scope information.
So if you look for--
if you access
a property X somewhere,
you want to be able to--to see
basically in your scopes
where is X declared?
But if you have a call to eval,
basically, you don't know
because eval can introduce
new bindings dynamically.
So you could introduce
a new X variable
in, uh, the context
where you're calling eval.
So basically, you just have
to give up
and say, statically,
I don't know.
Um, and there's similar issues
with, uh, "with" statements
in JavaScript.
So "with" statements are used
to introduce a new object
in your scope chain.
So if you want easy access
to all the properties
on the document object,
you can say with document
and then have a blog of code,
where if you just write a name
like "write"
that will be looked up
in the document object
so that will actually be
document.write.
And that's all fine.
But if you want to, uh,
have scope information again,
you have to give up
inside of a "with" statement
because you don't know.
Because it might look
like a variable is declared
and out of scope,
but, uh, dynamically,
you might introduce an object
with your "with" statement
that has that property name
as well.
And that's the one
that you need to get.
So overall,
JavaScript is very dynamic.
Um, and that makes it a bit
of a challenge
to implement it efficiently.
So let's talk
about what we did for V8
and which design decisions
we took.
So the goal for V8 was to create
a JavaScript engine
that would make, um, large
object-oriented applications
perform well.
So if you have large
object-oriented applications,
you're going to use
abstractions.
And if you use abstractions,
you're going to have a lot
of property accesses
and you're going to have
a lot of--of function calls.
And you're going to have
a lot of objects.
So that means
that in order to make
these kind of applications
run fast,
you need fast property
access,
calls,
and you need fast and scalable
memory management.
So you want to be able to handle
a large number of objects,
um, efficiently.
So these goals led
to three key components of V8.
So the first component
is something called
hidden classes
and hidden class
transitions.
Um, so hidden classes
is basically our notion
of types.
Um, so JavaScript does not have
any types.
And we're not adding types
to JavaScript
or anything like that.
But internally
in the JavaScript engine,
we have a notion of type
and that's our hidden class.
And I'll--I'll tell you more
about that.
So once we have that, we--
we, uh, we can use a technique
called inline caching.
Um, so we generate native code
for all of our JavaScript.
And we also generate code
on the fly
and use a technique
called inline caching.
So these two things together,
hidden classes
and native code generation
with inline caching,
gives us fast property access
and fast function calls.
So those are the two
first items.
Um, so the second thing
that we wanted
was, uh, a fast memory
management system.
Um, so we use,
uh, a generational garbage
collector.
And it's pretty much standard,
but it works really well.
Um, and that means that,
uh, having a generational
garbage collector,
we scale well to dealing
with a lot of objects.
And I'll tell you some more
about that as well.
Okay, so let's, uh,
let's dig in.
So to set the scene,
let me start
by telling you a bit
about V8's memory model.
Um, so in V8, we use,
uh, 32-bit tagged pointers.
Um, all of our objects
in our heap
are, uh, 4-byte aligned.
And that means
that if you have a pointer
to a JavaScript object, uh,
the two least significant bits
are going to be zero.
So we can use that knowledge
to actually,
um, do pointer tagging.
Since we know that all pointers
should have
the two least significant bits,
zero,
we can actually put in
ones there,
uh, to--to give
some extra information
to our pointers.
And then we just make sure
to strip them
if we actually need
the actual pointer.
Um, so what we use that for
is allowing 32--
sor--sorry--
31-bit signed integers
to be immediate values.
And they're distinguished
from real pointers by tagging.
So if you'll, uh, load a pointer
to a JavaScript object
from a heap and the address
is even--
it's actually not a pointer.
It's an immediate
integer value.
And you get the integer value
by just shifting,
uh, one bit right.
So basically shifting
the zero away.
And that's going to be
you're, uh, integer value.
So that means
that we can have efficient,
um, we can deal with integers
efficiently,
uh, because they're just
immediate values
and we don't have
to do any heap allocation
to handle integers.
Um, so on the other hand,
if you load, um, a pointer
to an object from our heap
and it's odd,
so it has the least significant
bit of one,
then it is an actual pointer.
And the pointer to the object
is this value
where you subtract one.
So where you clear the tag.
Okay, so, um,
our base JavaScript objects
consist of three words.
The first word
is a hidden class pointer.
Um, so this is our notion
of type as I told you before.
And I'll--I'll get into details
on that in a second.
Uh, and the two other pointers
are used
to point to where
we actually hold
the values of properties.
So we split the property's
backing storage
into two parts,
one is for properties
that are named by strings.
So like X, Y, and Z.
And the other one
is for what we call "elements,"
which are basically properties
which have integer names.
So 012 and so on.
Um, so all
of our JavaScript objects
are these three-word
thingies.
Okay, and the backing storage
for properties and for elements
can be in two
different states,
namely a fast case
and a slow case.
So in the fast case,
uh, a property's backing storage
or an element's backing storage
is just an array,
where we can do
direct indexing.
And in the slow case,
it's going to be a dictionary
or a HashMap.
Okay, so now we're ready
to talk about hidden classes.
So, uh, as I told you,
in static, object-oriented,
uh, languages
where you have classes,
uh, you can do really fast
property access
because the class describes
your object
and you know exactly
where to find the properties
of your object.
So we wanted to have the same
ability for JavaScript.
We wanted to be able to do,
like, a few,
uh, assembly instructions
to load a property.
Um, so to use these
normal optimization techniques,
we needed to introduce
a notion of type.
And for that, we use
hidden classes.
So hidden classes,
uh, are classes,
but they're only internal
to the--
to the JavaScript engine.
So it's something
that we keep track of
and users don't know about.
Um, and hidden classes
group objects
that have the exact same
structure.
Okay, so talking
about hidden classes,
it's easiest to just,
uh, have an example.
So, um, in JavaScript,
all objects are created
from--from, uh,
from functions.
Um, and here's
a point function,
which is a constructive
function
that we can use
to construct points.
And it just takes two arguments
and assigns them
to the, uh, X and Y properties
of the resulting object.
Okay, so the goal here
is that any point
that we construct
should end up having,
uh, the point map, basically,
the point hidden class.
So JavaScript objects created
in the same way
should end up having
the same hidden class
because they'll have
the same internal structure.
Okay.
Um, so in this example,
I'm going to create two points.
I'm going to show you
how they end up
having the same
hidden class.
So since all JavaScript objects
are created from functions,
we create an initial class
for each function.
So the point function here
is going to have
an initial class,
which is called class zero,
which I've put up there.
And this is the class--
the hidden class--
that we're going to give,
uh, to all new objects created
from the point function.
So when we, uh, create
our first point here, p1,
that's this three-word thing
that has a pointer
to hidden class.
And since this object
was created
using the point function,
it's initial class is going
to be the initial class
of the point function,
class zero.
And then it has properties
and elements as well.
And in the beginning,
we're going to allocate
a small piece of--
of backing storage
both for properties
and for elements.
Um, so that's--
that's the initial thing
that you get
when you say a new point.
And then we're going
to start executing the body
of the point function
with this newly allocated object
as the--this pointer.
Okay, so the first thing
that we're going to do
is add an X-property
to this object.
So adding a property
to an object
changes the structure
of the object,
which means that we need
to change the hidden class
of the object.
So when we assign X
to this property,
we need to create
a new class.
And we do that by copying
the original class,
which is class zero,
and then adding the knowledge
to that class
that we have an X-property.
and that--that property
is at offset zero
in our backing storage.
And then we're going
to put the value
into the backing storage
at offset zero.
And importantly,
we're going to remember
in class zero
that if you have an object
that has class zero
and you add a property
with the name X,
then you need to transition
to class one.
So that's what we call
a hidden class transition.
Another similar thing happens
when we add the Y-property.
So adding a new property
to an object
changes its structure.
And therefore it needs
to change its hidden class.
So we create
a new hidden class
by copying class one.
We add the knowledge
that we have a Y-property
and that the value
of the Y-property
is at offset one
in our backing storage.
We fill in value.
And we, uh, update
the hidden class pointer
to point
to this new class.
And again, we remember
in class one
that if you have an object
that has class one
and you add a Y-property
to it,
then you need to transition
to class two.
Okay, so that finishes
the construction
of our first point.
So you see this is actually
a pretty heavy weight
to construct the first object
from a constructive function
because we need to create
all of these new classes
by copying existing ones
and adding a bit of information.
Um, but that only costs
on the first construction.
So on the next construction,
um, we're basically going
to do the same thing,
but we're going
to reuse our classes.
So if we go to the construction
of, uh, of p2,
that will create
a new object,
which is this
three-way thing.
The initial class
is going to be the class
associated
with the point function,
which is going to be c0.
Class zero.
And then we're going
to execute the body
of the point function.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is assign, um, is to add
an X-property to our object.
So now this point
has class zero.
And in class zero,
there's information
that if you have an object
that has class zero,
and you add a property
called X,
well, then you need
to transition to class one.
So that's what we're going
to do.
So for the assignment to X,
we're just going to update
the hidden class pointer
and put the value
in the backing storage.
And similarly for Y,
we now have an object
of class one.
In class one, we know
that if you add a Y property,
you need to transition
to class two.
So that's all we're going
to do.
We're just going to update
the hidden class pointer
and, uh, add the value
to the backing storage.
So now we've created
two point objects.
They've been created
in exactly the same way.
And they end up sharing
the hidden class, class two.
And the important thing here
is that in class two,
we have a complete description
of our objects.
We know that all objects
that have class two
will have X at offset zero
in the backing storage
and Y at offset one.
And we can use that
to optimize property accesses.
So let me revisit
my previous statement.
So I said that JavaScript
is really challenging
to implement because
it's really, really dynamic.
And that's true.
So in JavaScript,
you have a lot of features
that allow you to write
really, really dynamic code.
But it turns out
that if you write,
uh, nice,
well-factored code,
in most cases, you'll have,
like, parts of your code
that deal with objects
that have a certain structure.
So now that we have
hidden classes,
we can instrument
our JavaScript engine
to actually collect information
about the hidden classes
that hit certain access sites.
And it turns out that 90%
of the cases
or maybe even more,
uh, only objects
having the same hidden class
are ever seen.
So that means that,
basically, you know something
about the structure
of your objects
when you've seen an object once
at an access site.
And that's what we're, uh,
and that's what we're going
to do to, uh, to--
to optimize.
Um, so basically,
at runtime,
JavaScript is not that
dynamic.
You basically see things
that have the same structure
again and again and again
and again.
So we can use that.
Um, so the only problem here
is that when we generate
the JavaScript code--
sorry, the native code
for our JavaScript code,
um, we don't know
the hidden class
of an object
at an access site,
uh, because we have
no type information
in the language.
Um, so that means
that we only know something
about our objects
when we see the first object
at an access site.
Um, so in order
to handle this,
we use runtime
code generation.
And we use a technique called
inline caching.
So here's
a very simple picture
of what inline caching
is like.
So in the beginning,
we just generate native code
for our JavaScript code.
And at all access sites,
we have absolutely no knowledge.
So if we want to load
an X-property,
we're just going to call
a piece of code
that's going to do
a completely generic
full lookup, uh, through
our objects
to see if they can find--
uh, if it can find
the property.
But once
we've done that once,
we have some extra
information.
We know the hidden class
of the object
that we've just looked at.
And we know, um,
where we found the property
in this object.
And based on that knowledge,
we can generate a small snippet
of new code that's going to be
really fast.
Um, and it's going to assume
that the next time we get here,
we're going to see
the same hidden class again.
So then we're going
to rewrite the code.
So that at this access site,
we're not going to go
to the fully generic code.
But we're actually going
to hit the fast lookup code.
And the only thing
the fast lookup code has to do
is validate our assumptions.
So it needs to check that
the next object that gets here
actually has the same
hidden class
as the first one.
And if it does,
then it knows exactly
where to load
the--the property value.
Okay, and if the assumptions
are broken--
so if we get here
with another type of object--
well, then we bail out
and then we go
to the fully generic
lookup again.
And again, that's the same
for all access sites.
When we've seen the first,
uh, object at an access site,
we generate a new piece
of code
to do a fast lookup
the next time.
Um, and that's
with the assumption
that we get the same
hidden class again.
If we don't,
then we bail out
and do a full generate lookup.
Okay, so what does
the fast case look like?
So it looks like this.
Um, and I've actually
given you
all of the information
that you need to--
to completely understand
what's going on here.
So let me try to step--
step through it.
So this is the--
the small snippet of code
that we generate to access
a property on an object.
So the first couple
of lines here,
the first line
just loads the receiver
from the stack
into register eax, okay?
So as I told you,
we use tag pointers.
So either--so now
we've loaded something.
Okay. So now we need to check
if it's an object
or if it's
an immediate value.
Uh, maybe a small integer.
So that's what the second line
here is doing.
It--it, uh, tests
if the least significant bit
of eax is one.
If it is,
this is an object pointer.
If it's not, it's an immediate
integer value
for which this snippet
doesn't really do anything.
So we're going to jump out
and go do the generic case
if that's the--
if--if that's happening.
So if we see an integer here,
we're just bailing out.
So the--the first lines here
are just loading the receiver,
checking that it's an object.
So the next couple
of lines here
are validating
our assumptions.
And our assumption is
that we're going to see
the same hidden class again.
So this piece of code
was generated with the knowledge
that the first,
uh, that the hidden class
of the first object
that got here
was at address
whatever's there.
0xf78 and so on.
Okay. So now we need to check
that the hidden class
of a current object
is the same one.
So we're going to load
from eax minus one.
So that's removing the tagging
from the pointer
and loading a pointer
from there,
which is the map pointer,
and we're just comparing that
to what we saw before.
If it's the same,
we're happy
and we load
the properties array
from our object.
And from the properties array,
we load the property value
directly.
And then we return.
So in the fast case,
all we need to do
is check our assumptions.
We load the receiver.
Check that it's an object.
Check that it has the correct
hidden class.
And then directly load
the property.
So that's a few assembly line
instructions.
And that's really,
really fast.
And if any of
our assumptions break,
if we either get an integer
or if the class does not match,
then we bail out and go
to a fully generic lookup.
Okay, so basically,
I've told you now
about two states
that our inline caches
can be in.
There's actually a third
as well.
So the three inline cache states
that we have
are uninitialized,
which is where
everything begins.
We don't know anything yet.
We haven't seen
any objects here.
So once we see
the first object,
we transition
to monomorphic,
which means that we've
only seen one hidden class
at this access site.
If we see more hidden classes
at the same access site,
we go into what's called
a megamorphic state.
And that just means
we've seen more types here.
Um, and in that case,
we actually use a cache
of generated
fast-case stubs.
So if we've already generated
a stub
for the, uh, this hidden class
that we're seeing
and this property,
we use that.
And otherwise, we go
to the full generic lookup.
So even if we see,
uh, multiple different classes
at the same access site,
we're actually trying
to--to use
some of our optimized stubs.
Another thing worth,
uh, knowing
about inline caches in V8
is that we clear them
on full garbage collections.
And that might sound odd.
So we've just spent time
generating code on the fly.
Uh, and now we just
throw it all away.
So the reason for that is that,
first of all,
it allows us to get rid
of unused code stubs.
So all of the code
that we generate
is allocated
in the JavaScript heap
like any other JavaScript
object.
And it flows freely around.
Um, so in order to be able
to, uh, to throw it away,
uh, we need to clear
inline caches
so there are no pointers,
uh, to these stubs.
Um, so if you have
an application
where you have, like,
a couple of stages--
so in the first stage,
you set up a lot of stuff.
And you do a lot of things
with one piece of code.
And then basically
you transition to some other--
to--to, like, another phase
where you use, basically,
another piece of code.
We don't want to keep
all the code objects alive
from the first piece of code
because if they're not going
to be used anymore,
that's a waste.
Um, so clearing inline caches
at full garbage collections
allows us to get rid
of unused code stubs.
The other thing that clearing,
um, inline caches
at full garbage collection
gives us
is the ability
to actually go back
to the fast case
if we hit the slow case
where we've seen multiple
different hidden classes
at an access site.
But basically,
we've transitioned
to another, like, phase
of the program
where we're only seeing objects
with the same,
uh, with the same
hidden class.
Uh, then we basically
don't want to get stuck
in the situation
where we think that we've seen
multiple, uh, things.
So clearing inline caches
on--on full garbage collection
gives our inline caches
the ability
to go back to the fast
monomorphic case again.
Okay, so, um,
that was,
uh, an introduction
to how we make
property accesses fast.
So there are
two things here.
There are the hidden classes
and--and the transition
between hidden classes.
And there's native code
generation with inline caching.
So the next thing I'd like
to--to tell you about
is, uh,
our memory management.
So we use a precise generational
garbage collector.
And what we really want here
is, uh,
to get in a situation
where the JavaScript engine
scales well.
So if you have a lot
of objects,
uh, and a lot of, like,
big data structures
when you run your program,
we don't want
the garbage collector
to have to look
at all of these objects
every time it has to, uh,
uh, reclaim, uh, some memory
because that's going to lead
to big pause times
and it's going to degrade
your performance.
Because every time you need
to get some free memory,
it has to look at everything.
So we don't want that.
So instead, we use generational
garbage collection.
Um, so we have
two generations.
We have a young generation,
which is one, small,
contiguous space,
which would
garbage collect often,
and then we have
an old generation,
uh, which is divided
into a number of spaces.
Um, and--and we only
occasionally garbage collect
the old generation.
So the reasoning here
is that, um,
in object-oriented programs,
most objects that you allocate
are going to be dead,
like, really soon.
You'll have a lot
of temporary objects.
Um, and the ones
that do not die immediately
are often long-lived.
So we allocate
all of our objects
in the young generation.
When--when we run
out of space
in the young generation,
we need to do
a garbage collection.
But we only garbage collect
the young generation.
And since most objects
that are allocated
die really young,
there'll be a lot
of dead objects
in our young generation.
So we can get rid
of most of them.
And then we'll be ready
to allocate again.
So there's no reason for us
to look at the old generation
if we can free enough,
uh, memory
from the--from the young
generation.
Um, so objects that survive
in the young generation
will be promoted
to the old generation
and then will continue.
Okay, so, um, the old
generation, as I said,
is divided up into a number
of spaces.
And I'm not going to go
into a lot of details with that.
But, so--so the reasons
for having multiple spaces
is basically to be able
to, uh, um, manage the--
the bookkeeping
in our memory management
system.
So for instance,
uh, we need--we have pages
that are 8, uh, 8K big.
So if we have objects
that are larger than that,
then we're not going
to allocate them
in the normal way.
So we have a special space
for large objects.
Uh, and also,
uh, as I said,
we're dynamically generating
native code on the fly.
Um, so we need one space
that's executable,
uh, where we generate
our native code
and run it from there.
Um, so that's
the code space.
And then there are a number
of other spaces.
Good.
So which types of garbage
collection do we use?
Um, I'm sorry about that.
My slides
are a bit messed up here.
Uh, I think we'll be fine.
So, um, we have three types
of garbage collection.
So the first one
is a scavenge collect.
A scavenge.
And on a scavenge collection,
uh, we only look
at the young generation.
So this is what we do
all the time.
Uh, and that's,
uh, copying collection.
Um, which means
that it's leaning on the size
of the live data.
And as I told you,
a lot of data dies--
a lot of objects die
really young.
So that means
that most of your data
in the young generation
is going to be dead.
And since this, uh, garbage
collection technique
is leaning on the size
of live objects,
it's going to be really fast
because there's not going
to be much live data.
So typical pause times
for a scavenge
is one to two milliseconds.
Um, and we do that
all the time.
Okay, so once in awhile,
we've actually, uh, promoted
enough objects
that we should, um, try
to clear up
the old generation as well.
Um, so once in awhile,
we do full garbage collections.
And we have two flavors
of those.
So the first one
is a non-compacting collection.
So that's a mark-sweep
collection
of both young and old
generation.
And in the non-compacting
version,
all free memory
gets added to free lists
and we allocate from there.
Um, and this might cause
fragmentation.
So, um, so fragmentation's
not good.
So that's why we have
a--another way
of garbage collection.
Um, okay, so a typical
pause time
for, like, really big
applications
for a full,
uh, non-compacting collection
is up to 50 milliseconds.
Often, you'll see
a lot smaller.
But if you're building
really big applications,
you can see pause times
up to 50 milliseconds.
So the last type of garbage
collection that we have
is a full compacting
collection.
Uh, and that's
a mark-sweep-compact collection
of both generations.
And instead
of adding free memory
to free lists,
we compact everything.
So we move all of the objects
to the beginning of pages
um, to get rid
of the fragmentation.
So basically, inside of V8,
we have a notion of--
we have an idea
of how much fragmentation
we've created.
And when we reach
a certain threshold,
we're going to do a non--
sorry, a compacting collection
to get rid
of the fragmentation.
Okay, so getting rid
of fragmentation
means that we need
to copy a lot of objects.
So if you're building
a really large application,
uh, you might get pause times
of up to 100 milliseconds here.
Yeah.
Oh, so the question is
"how big is the, uh, is the--
is the young generation?"
Um, it's not very big.
It's, like, wow,
honestly,
I don't even remember.
I think it's--it's--
it's a megabyte or two.
Something like that.
So the--so--I'm not sure
I understand the question.
So you're saying
that if I have an application
that allocates
a lot of small objects--
a lot of small objects,
uh, and then you're saying
that then
the young generation's
going to be scanned
frequently?
Well, no, not really.
So--so the--so, um,
so if you allocate
a lot of small objects,
yes, they're going
to be allocated
in the--
in the young generation.
Um, so if--if when you--
so when you fill out
the young generation
and you don't have
any more room,
you need to garbage collect.
So at that point,
you look at all the live data
and then it's true
that if all of your objects
are still live,
then you're going to look
through all of them, basically.
But if they survive,
then you're going to move them
to the old generation
and you're not going to look
at them again.
Yeah. But, yeah,
you're right.
I mean, as long as you just
allocate,
uh, and--and keep
everything alive,
it's going to be allocated
in the young generation,
and you're going
to scan all of them
and basically move them
to the old generation
so you don't have to look
at them the next time.
Yeah.
Oh, the timing of these?
Uh, these are on, uh,
all desktop--desktop machines.
Uh, and--and, uh, so basically
running inside of Chrome
on, like, a modern machine--
desktop machine.
Okay.
So that covers the part
of how we made V8
handle, um, property accesses,
function calls,
and, um, uh, write really well
and be fast at that.
And how we made V8 scale,
uh, by using generational
garbage collection.
So now let me talk
a bit about,
uh, some recent developments.
So recently, we've, uh,
we've implemented
a new regular expression engine
for V8.
It's called Irregexp.
Um, so initially, V8,
um, actually
in the beginning,
like, completely
from the beginning
to get V8 up and running,
we use PCRE,
which is a standard library
for regular expression matching.
Um, the problem with PCRE
is that it does not match
JavaScript regular expression
semantics.
So you need something else.
Either you need
to modify PCRE
or you need to have,
like, a compatibility layer
that basically translates
PCRE regular expressions--
sorry, JavaScript regular
expressions
to their equivalent
PCRE regular expression
and then use PCRE.
Um, so luckily,
at WebKit,
they, uh, they had this problem
as well.
And they created a library
called JSCRE,
uh, which matched,
uh, JavaScript semantics.
So we switched to that.
So the initial version of V8
used a library,
uh, from WebKit
called JSCRE.
Um, so JSCRE did not fit V8
that well
so it didn't really
perform well.
And the reason for this
is that, uh, JSCRE,
uh, expected a different string
representation
than most strings in V8.
So in order to actually
hand off a string to JSCRE,
we would most of the time
have to do a string conversion.
And that's really costly.
Um, so this really didn't
perform very well.
So, uh, and we thought
that we could do--do better.
And we also thought
that we could do better
when it comes to algorithms,
uh, for regular expression
matching.
Uh, so we implemented our own
regular expression matching,
which has given us a 10x speedup
on regular expression matching
on our benchmarks.
Um, and our new library
implements
all of, uh, JavaScript
regular expressions.
So there's no fallback
to any other engines.
It's a full JavaScript regular
expression implementation.
So what's in there?
Um, well, first of all,
um, the new
regular expression engine
is based on an automata
approach.
So from an input regular
expression,
we build an automaton.
And then we perform
analysis
and optimization
on that automaton.
And then from the resulting
rewritten automaton,
we generate native code.
So all of your regular
expressions
are now executed,
uh, using native code.
And, um, in our analysis
and optimization phase,
we use a number of tricks
to, uh, to make,
um, regular expression matching
cheaper.
So we try
to avoid backtracking
and we try
to reorder operations
so that we perform
the least--
the least expensive
operations first.
So when you do regular
expression matching,
um, most of the time,
you do find a match
because you actually know
that it's going to be there--
at--at--that it's going
to be there somewhere.
But you start
from the beginning, right?
And maybe you have to scan,
uh, through a lot.
So basically, the common case
for regular expression matching
is that you don't have
a match.
For the first position,
you're probably not going
to have a match.
And so on.
Um, so reordering
operations
to perform the least expensive
operations first
gives us an opportunity
to--to fail
as quickly as possible,
which is actually
pretty important
when you do regular expression
matching.
Okay, so let me, uh,
let me give you
a couple of examples here.
Um, so one of the things
that we do,
uh, which is to avoid
backtracking,
is to search for common parts
of--in--in alternatives first.
So if you want to look
for either "Sun" or "Mon,"
then the common part
of this regular expression
is that the character
at index two
is going to be "n."
Okay.
So if, uh,
so if you search
and at the current position,
the thing that's at index two
is not an "n,"
then you're done.
Then you don't have to do
anything more
because then you know
that it can't match here.
So you need to move on.
Okay, so the more traditional
approach here
would be to start out
by the first alternative.
So you try to look
for "Sun."
So you might find S.
You might find u.
And then
you might not find n.
Then at that point,
all you know
is that you didn't match
"Sun."
So you have to try
the other alternative.
Uh, and that'll fail,
uh, by looking at the M.
All right.
But by, uh, looking
for common parts first,
we just have to do
one comparison
and we know that it's not
going to be here
for any of the alternatives.
So that avoids
a lot of backtracking.
Um, another nice thing
about the--our new regular
expression engine
is that, uh, in V8, we have
an ASCII representation
for most strings.
Uh, because a lot of strings
that are actually used
in JavaScript programs
are still ASCII strings.
Uh, and that means
that in a single compare
instruction,
you can actually, uh,
match up to four characters
at a time.
So in order to search
for "foobar,"
you'll just, um,
in an ASCII string,
you'll just load four bytes
into Word
and then you'll do a compare
against the bit parent
that's "foob."
Um, and then you're going
to load the next two characters,
which is two bytes,
and then you're going to do
a two-byte compare for those.
Um, so that's really nice
to have the ability
to actually match
four characters at a time.
That's really fast.
Okay, so here's an example
that shows you something
about reordering.
Um, so here's
a regular expression
that looks for "foobar"
that can be spelled
either with a normal F
or a capital F
and a normal B
or a capital B.
And then it's going to capture
whatever was matched.
Okay, so we want to perform
the cheap operations first.
So we're going to try
to begin by matching "oo"
and "ar"
at position one and four
because those are just,
like,
simple character
comparisons.
And those are really quick.
And if one of them fail,
well, then we can skip
all the rest.
Okay, so the next thing
we're going to do
is look for either F
or a capital F
at position zero.
And we're going to look for a B
or a capital B
at position three.
And then finally,
we're going to--to perform
the actual capture
operation.
Um, so the reordering here
is really just to get
the cheap operations first
because that allows us
to fail early and quickly.
Good.
So that's, uh, that's our new
regular expression engine.
So another thing
that we've done recently
is to change our compiler.
Uh, so the original compiler
was extremely simple.
Uh, just build an abstract
syntax tree.
It did no static analysis
of any kind.
It did no
register allocation.
So it just built an abstract
syntax tree.
And one pass
over the abstract syntax tree,
it--it would generate
a code.
Period.
Um, so we've now implemented
a new compile infrastructure,
which performs register
allocation.
It's still
a one-pass compiler.
Um, so for JavaScript,
since you get all of your code
over the network,
you need
your JavaScript engine
to--to be able
to run the code quickly.
So you need to, uh,
to have a fast compiler.
So it's still
a one-pass compiler.
But now it actually
does its best
to, uh, to do register
allocation as well.
And--and we're pretty
excited about this.
And we think that it'll--
that it'll form the basis
for further native code
optimizations in--in V8.
Okay, so that's what I wanted
to say about recent stuff.
Um, so now I'm going to talk
to something
that's quite different,
uh, but that I think
is really, really important.
Namely how well
your JavaScript engines scale
to deal with very large
applications.
Um, so why is that
important?
Well, so web applications
are becoming bigger and bigger
and more complex.
And with
the increased complexity,
you get more objects.
And more objects
put extra, uh, stress
on your memory management
system.
So if you do not have
a system that scale
to handle all of
these objects,
your performance
will suffer.
Um, so not only are applications
becoming bigger,
which means that they get
more objects,
but also, a lot of browsers
are still single process.
And most single process
browsers,
um, when you start up
multiple tabs
with multiple applications,
all of your JavaScript objects
are going to be allocated
in the same JavaScript
object heap.
Which means that you actually
get a lot of objects
in your JavaScript heap.
So if your memory management
system has to look
at all objects
for every garbage collection,
that's going to hurt you.
Um, right.
So it is actually
really important
that your JavaScript execution
is--is good
and is fast in these situations
as well.
And it's important now.
It's not--it's not only
for, like, the future.
It's also important now.
Um, right.
So our approach
to scalability
is to use generational
garbage collection,
as I've just
told you about.
Um, right.
So I've done a little
experiment here.
And I should say right now
that this is really,
really artificial.
So take all of this
with a grain of salt.
But it does--it does
illustrate my point.
Um, so my scalability
experiment,
um, was to take
the raytrace benchmark
from the V8 benchmark suite
and then run it
a number of times.
And on each iteration,
I'm going to allocate
some extra memory
in the JavaScript heap.
Um, and with V8,
the data structure
that I'm going to allocate,
I'm going to add one megabyte
of extra live data
per iteration.
And then I'm just going
to map out the performance--
so the benchmark score--
over these iterations
with an increased amount
of objects in your heap.
And the result looks like this
for, uh, for three browsers.
Um, so as you can see,
the performance
characteristics here
are quite different.
Um, so what we want
to get to here
is basically having
a straight line.
So as you can see,
uh, Chromium running V8
is not getting a straight line.
But it's also not, like,
dropping completely.
Um, and that's--that's pretty
much what you get
when you use a generational
garbage collection like we do.
So it does cost
to have larger heaps,
but your performance
does not completely degrade.
Um, so another
interesting thing
that you can see
from this graph
is that you have, like,
down spikes.
Um, so those down spikes
are when you get
to the full compacting
collections.
So if you actually get
to a point
where you need to do
a full compacting collection,
that's going to be visible
on graphs like, uh, like these.
So the interesting thing here
is that, like, Firefox 3.5,
beta 4,
uh, seems to be doing
very well
when it comes to scalability.
Uh, the benchmark score
is not that impressive
on the other hand.
Uh, Safari is doing really well
on the benchmark score.
Uh, but it seems
that there's something
like a full scan of the heap
on each garbage collection
because if you add extra data
to the heap,
then already at, like,
five megabytes,
they're at a third
of the speed that they had
with, uh, with a freshly,
uh, started browser.
Um, so I think
this really matters
because this is--I mean,
this is a benchmark, right?
So this is a benchmark
that's in our benchmark suite.
And this tells you something
about how valid
those benchmark results are
in the real world.
So if you have
a single process browser
and you open multiple tabs,
that's going to lead
to a lot of objects.
And, uh, and then
your performance
is going to be more like
what's on the right
of this, uh,
of this graph.
So I think that--that we need
to put some more emphasis
on this.
Uh, and I think
that it's really important,
um, because it's--
it's really important for--
for the real live
situations,
having many tabs
or having big applications.
Um, so in order
to put a bit of focus on this,
uh, we've, um, we've published
a new benchmark
in the V8 benchmark suite.
Which is again completely
artificial.
So it builds a splay tree,
uh, roughly the size
of, like, 30 megabytes,
something like that.
And then it just performs
operations on the splay tree.
Which means that it allocates
new nodes,
it modifies the splay tree,
and it garbage collects, uh,
nodes that have been removed.
Um, right,
so we really want to try
to, like,
put some emphasis on this.
Uh, we want scalability.
We want browsers to be scalable.
We want people to actually get
the JavaScript performance
that they expect
when they run the JavaScript
benchmarks out there.
Uh, those should basically
reflect what you get in reality.
So again, this experiment
is completely artificial.
Uh, if you want to try this,
uh, take your browsers,
load a number of tabs,
run benchmarks,
um, or try something else.
Try writing really big
web applications
and see how well,
uh, JavaScript behaves
under a bit of stress.
Good. So that finishes
my scalability rant.
Um, good.
So let me tell you a bit
about the performance
bottlenecks
that I see for--
for V8 currently.
Um, so one of the bottlenecks
that we have is that, um,
we only generate
one, uh, fully general version
of all code that we generate.
That means that we are not
basically allowed
to have that many assumptions
in our code.
Because we need to handle
all the special cases
in the code that we generate.
So that means that we have
a lot of checking
for basically exceptional
situations in our code,
like situations that basically
do not happen in reality.
Um, so one thing
that we should explore
is generating multiple versions
of the same code.
So generating--
uh, in the beginning,
generating a really optimized
version of the code
that avoids a lot
of the checking.
And then if some
of our checks fail,
then basically bail out
to a slower version of the code.
So at that point, generate
another version of the code.
So that should give us
a big performance gain.
Um, another,
uh, bottleneck
is that our use
of inline caching
is based on calls to stubs.
So we generate these stubs
and then we use,
like, a call instruction
to actually get
to that code.
Um, and that's good
for a code size
because we just have
a call instruction in there.
But it's not necessarily
the best thing we can do
for our performance.
So in some situations,
we might actually want
to inline the code instead
directly in the code stream.
So instead of having
the call,
we can just have the code
directly there.
Uh, and that
actually matters.
Uh, and we have done that
for a couple of simple cases
of loads.
And it really does matter.
So the downside to that
is code size.
So your code becomes bigger
when you actually inline.
Okay, so another issue,
which is basically,
uh, related
to doing more inlining
is our write barrier.
Um, so since we use
generational garbage collection,
um, and we, uh,
garbage collect
the young generation often,
we need to know
about all pointers
into the young generation.
And that includes
all of the pointers
from objects
in the old generation
to pointers
in the new generation.
And that means that whenever
we store a pointer
in an old generation object,
we might have
to record somewhere
that this object
is actually referring
to a new space object.
And that's done by something
called a write barrier.
And right now,
our write barrier is a bit
complicated.
It has a lot of instructions,
and it's a bit slow.
So we should experiment
with--with new ways
of implementing
our write barrier.
Um, and the reason
why that's related
to, uh, inlining more code
is that since our write
barrier's pretty big,
it's not really practical
to inline stores
directly in the code
because all stores
need to have the write barrier
inline as well.
And that will lead
to a lot of, uh,
of code size, uh, increase.
Okay,
and the last thing here,
I don't really want
to talk much about.
But--but basically,
there are a lot of global loads
in JavaScript code.
And we handle global loads
the same way as any other loads.
And basically,
we don't have to.
So we could generate
better code for that.
Um, so another thing
that I didn't put up here,
but which is also
really important,
is, uh, DOM performance.
And basically, we haven't
done much, uh, in that area
to really,
really optimize it.
Um, so that's another thing
that we should do.
Uh, we should look more
at DOM performance.
So the interaction
between JavaScript
and--and the DOM.
Good.
So to summarize,
V8 was designed
both for speed
and for scalability.
Uh, the goal of V8 is
to raise the performance bar
for JavaScript.
So we want to continue
to push
and see if we can make
JavaScript even faster.
And, um, we don't want
to just push
for Google
and for Google Chrome.
We really want to--
to try to see if we can--
if we can inspire other
JavaScript vendors as well.
And therefore,
our full source code
is available
under a BSD license.
And, unfortunately,
the URL scrolled out of
my slides here.
But it's at
code.google.com/p/v8.
Should be pretty easy
to find.
So the graph
that I've put up here
that I'd like to end with
is the, um,
is what has happened to
the V8 benchmark score
over time.
So, um, the versions
that you see on the left
are Google Chrome versions.
So this basically started
in September of 2008
with a 1.0 beta.
And since then,
we've just continued to push.
And we will continue
to do that.
So that's all.
Thanks.
[applause]
Questions.
Yes.
Yeah, that's a good point.
So the question is,
in my example of hidden classes
and hidden class transitions,
I added first X and then Y.
So what would happen
if I added Y first and then X?
And the, uh, and the answer is
that that would be
a different hidden class.
Um, so, uh,
it's really common
for objects to be allocat--
to be generated
in exactly the same way.
Um, so that's basically
what saves us.
But you're right.
They're objects that basically
have the same structure,
namely a Y-property
and an X-property,
um, they can actually
get completely different maps
if you first add Y and then X
and then in another place
add X and then Y.
Those would be separate
hidden classes.
Yeah.
Okay. So what if you declare
an object
through an object literal
and not through a function?
Uh, that's not going
to be a problem
because object literals
are also created
based on a function--
namely the object function.
And the object function
has an initial map.
Um, so basically,
uh, the same thing works.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's a good question.
So the question is
do we only apply this
to user-defined objects
or do we also use this
on, like, built-in stuff
like date, math, number,
whatever?
And the answer is that,
yes, we also do it
on built-in stuff.
Uh, and to go a bit deeper,
our built-in stuff is actually
implemented in JavaScript.
So we don't implement that
in C++.
We actually have it implemented
in JavaScript--a lot of it.
Um, so that means that basically
the same thing applies.
So it's going to go through
exactly the same path.
And the cool thing about that
is that if we improve
our overall JavaScript
performance,
we're also going to improve
the speed of our libraries.
Um, so that's one cool thing
about having libraries
written in JavaScript.
Another cool thing
is that, um,
uh, it's really easy and quick
to go change stuff.
Um, so it also does lead to--
to some extra complication
in the sense that in order
to set up
your math, number,
date objects,
you actually have to look
at JavaScript code.
You actually have to compile
JavaScript code.
So to overcome that,
uh, we--we use something
called snapshotting.
So, um, yes,
this is becoming
a longer explanation.
Sorry about that.
So--so basically,
in the beginning,
the first time that we--
that we, uh--
so when we build V8,
we start up V8 once,
we load the basic libraries.
That gives us a heap
that contains all of the code
for our basic libraries.
We dump that heap
as a binary image to a file.
And then we integrate
that binary data
into a new version of V8
that we built
so that when you start V8,
even though your libraries
are written in JavaScript,
you don't have to--to pass
and compile any JavaScript code
to get your native libraries.
All you do is just slurp
in that binary data
and you're up and running.
Yeah.
So the question is
"if there are any JavaScript
design patterns
that I know of that perform
better than others."
Um, so my answer to that
would be no.
But also, my answer to that
should be that,
uh, that it shouldn't matter
that much.
So basically, you shouldn't
worry about it.
We should hopefully be able
to make it fast.
Um, but as you've seen
with the techniques
that we used here,
we're kind of, uh, somehow
relying on user build to--
to do something
that's, like, well structured,
uses abstractions,
and does not,
like, uh, try
to be overly general
and try to have, like, code
that's, like, really using
a million different--
operating on a million
different types.
But, um, but that shouldn't
really be an issue
because in--
in most application code
that you write,
you might have parts
of the code that's like that
that's really generic
and then you have most
of your code, which is not.
So basically, you shouldn't
have to worry about it.
That should be, uh,
that should be us worrying.
Oh.
Okay, so, uh,
the question is if I can--
can give some information
about other browsers
that are starting to use--
that are using
these techniques
and, uh, also if it's being
fed back to WebKit.
Yeah.
So, um...
so, uh,
Apple's JavaScript engine,
I guess it's called Nitro
by now,
uh, is using
these techniques as well,
which is really cool.
So I think that's--
that's great.
And they're getting
great performance gains
the same way that we did
by using these techniques.
So they use, uh,
what we call hidden classes
and inline caching as well.
Uh, I think they call
their hidden classes
structure IDs or something
like that.
But they use
the same techniques,
which is really cool.
Um, feeding it back
to WebKit,
yes, we are doing that
in the sense
that the binding layer,
so the--
the layer that binds V8
into the DOM
is being upstreamed
to WebKit.
So that actually lives
at WebKit now.
Um, so hopefully it should be
fairly easy going forward
to use V8 instead of Nitro
if you want to in WebKit.
man: Any--over here.
Over here.
Ager: Oh, yes.
man:
Any performance boosts
to the lambda
functional closures
optimizing
the call stacks?
Ager: I'm not sure
I understand the question.
Could you repeat, please?
man: Is there
a performance boost
to the handling of the lambda
functions closures?
Ager: Oh, if we have
any performance boosts
on--on closures.
Uh...
so...
well, basically,
I mean, that code is handled
like--like all other code.
So it gets, like,
the same kind of benefits
that--that the rest
of the code does.
So--so yes.
So I think we're running
out of time.
So--so I think
I should stop now.
So you're all welcome
to come talk to me afterwards.
So if you have other questions,
please come talk to me.
[applause]